Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
recorded login sequences. So recorded login sequences are kind of our one-size-fits-all
solution for the many different ways of authenticating that are out there on the
modern web. Burp Scanner out-of-the-box will handle really simple login forms that just have
a username and a password field, but those aren't too prevalent these days. So instead,
recorded login sequences enable you to handle any arbitrary logins that are out there, rather than
having us try to support everything out of the box and always playing catch-up. We can just handle
anything that can be recorded and replayed. So I'm going to dive into Burp and I'm going to show you
how to record one, how to replay it, to check that it's working. And if I remember, because this is
like take five now, I'm going to show you some tips as well. So let's dive in. So first off, let's head
into the proxy browser. Here we go. So the proxy browser comes bundled with the Burp Suite extension,
which has the recorded Burp Suite navigation recorder. You can go and install this extension in
your own Chrome installation from the extension store if you'd like, but it comes pre-bundled with
the proxy browser. So if we start recording, I'm going to head over to Gin and Juice Shop.
This is Portswigger's deliberately vulnerable application. And if you're familiar with it,
you might notice that we've had a bit of a rebrand recently. It looks really snazzy now.
And usefully for us, it has a multi-step login. So if we head over, here's our login form.
Handily, it tells us what our username should be. And because it's deliberately vulnerable,
it tells us what our password should be, which is handy for me because it means I don't have to
remember it. So if we log in. So one tip that we suggest people use if they're having issues where
their final page after their login takes a long time to load is to click on something arbitrary
on the page that's only there when it's fully loaded. So we will try after the recorded sequence
is done to make sure the final page is fully rendered before moving on. But giving us a hint
as to what should be there when it is fully rendered makes things a lot smoother. If your page is nice
and responsive, it's not too necessary. But when people are having issues, it's one of the first
things we suggest. So now that's recorded. If we head back to the extension, and we stop recording,
we head into BERT. Now we can replay it to check that it works. So if we open up a new scan and head
over to the application login section, we can say that we want to use a recorded login sequence.
We paste that in. Let's call it Carlos. Hit OK. And go and replay.
So we can see it here step by step, doing everything we told to do and verify that it lands on the page
we expected it to land on. And that's pretty much it. As I said, we do hope that recorded logins mean
that we can handle any arbitrary login form that's out there. But there are exceptions. There are always
edge cases. So if you are having issues, please definitely feel free to get in touch with support,
and we'll take a look for you.
Thank you.